now as you may know i've done a lot of
videos on the gallbladder
and bile salts because of the great
importance of that organ
which is typically considered an extra
organ that you don't need but
the gallbladder is very very important
it helps you store
and concentrate bile salts
now your liver makes bile and so do your
friendly
bacteria now about 95 to 97
of all the bile that you your body makes
is recycled
so bile is very very important and when
you take
bile salts as a supplement normally
people
take that with a meal they might take it
just after they eat
and it will usually help with bloating
belching
burping and nausea now the primary
function of bile salts that most people
know is the extraction of the fat
soluble vitamins
from the fat in your diet but there are
many other benefits of using purified
bowel salts
and taking them on an empty stomach now
i've pretty much purchased
every single medical textbook on both
the gall bladder and bile salt so it's a
fascinating topic
i want to share with you the nine
benefits
of taking purified bile salts and for
these benefits i'm going to discuss
i would recommend taking purify bath
salts on an empty stomach
i would take one in the morning and one
in the afternoon
all right number one taking purify bile
salts can help you reduce the risk of
getting gallstones
why because a gallstone is a super
concentrated
gallbladder crystal compound
and bile salts help you prevent the
formation
of cholesterol crystals okay that's
number one
number two it helps you extract the fat
soluble vitamins vitamin a
e d vitamin k and the omega-3 fatty
acids
and what it does to fat is it emulsifies
the fat it breaks down the fat into
these small
particles which increase the surface
area
so the pancreas can release its
enzyme called lipase which then does the
rest of the dissolving
of that fat particle so you can fully
extract
those nutrients from that food and so
you need
both bile and the enzyme from the
pancreas to make this
successful all right number three it can
help you with constipation
bile is kind of a lubricant it helps to
lubricate the colon
and so when you're deficient in bile you
can become constipated
now if you have too much bile you can
get diarrhea because it actually
releases a lot of water
in through the intestines specifically
the large intestine
so that's why you need just the right
amount number four
bile helps you convert thyroid hormones
t4
is the inactive version of the thyroid
hormone
and t3 is the active form you need bile
to make this transition from t4 to t3
and this is why sometimes when people
have their gallbladder removed
and they become gallbladder deficient
they may end up with a thyroid
problem the simple solution is just to
start taking purified bowel salts
because that will help
the thyroid greatly and one
contraindication of taking purify bile
salts
is if you have too many thyroid hormones
so if you have a
hyperthyroid condition you never want to
take bile salts because that's going to
increase
more conversion and make things worse
but for a hypo
thyroid condition purified bile salts
can help you greatly
now number five is very interesting
bile salts can act as a vdr
agonist now what the heck does that mean
vitamin d
receptor agonist bile helps you
trigger the receptor for vitamin d
now this is very important in autoimmune
diseases because
the problem with autoimmune conditions
is that you have this massive
inflammation and vitamin d is the most
important vitamin
in dropping inflammation and if you have
an autoimmune condition
and you don't have any inflammation you
really don't have
hardly any symptoms from that condition
and so bile can help you
indirectly reduce inflammation in the
body
especially the liver all right number
six
bile salts can help you decrease pain in
your body
specifically in the right shoulder
simply because if you have a congested
gallbladder or there's congestion
between the liver and the ducts going to
the gall bladder or the small intestine
a lot of times
this bile will form sludge because
you're missing bile
and that congestion will back up the
pipes
and put pressure into the liver and
cause pain in the right shoulder
as well as trigger a nerve that goes
from your diaphragm up to
your neck called the phrenic nerve and
cause right shoulder pain
right trap pain up through here pain in
the rhomboid muscle in the back
part here it can also cause pain on the
right side
causing a headache on the right side of
your head it can also cause pain and
tightness underneath the right rib cage
or in the stomach area or underneath the
left ribcage
and even pancreatitis because what can
happen
is this bile sludge can back up
and now you have your bile salts which
are detergents
that are not moving properly and they're
stuck
in the bile ducts in the liver and even
in the pancreatic ducts and if it's
stagnant or doesn't move
that can create inflammation and so by
taking
purified bile salts that thins the
sludge
and allows things to drain through and
the pain goes away and so a lot of the
pain
problems are coming from a deficiency of
bile
and as a side note let me just mention
the reasons why you might be deficient
in bile number one you have the
gallbladder removed
number two you're on a low fat diet
number three you're taking
too many omega-6 fatty acids
as in soy oil canola
cottonseed oil corn oil all these
cooking
vegetable oils that we consume are very
very damaging to the liver and they can
create a big problem
if you're consuming too much sugar
refined grains or you have a spike in
insulin
that can decrease your bile if you're
estrogen dominant or you're taking birth
control pills
and the estrogen spikes that can create
a deficiency in
bile if your liver is fatty or you have
hepatitis
or you have cirrhosis and there's liver
damage
that can decrease the production of bile
right there if you have high levels of
cortisol or you're taking prednisone
which is a type of cortisol
that can create a deficiency of bile soy
protein isolates can greatly aggravate
the gallbladder and the liver and cause
a deficiency of bile
having too many exotoxins let's say for
example
you did a detox and you're breaking up
bacteria or virus particles
and that's releasing these endotoxins
which by the way create the detox
reactions that occur when you do a detox
what happens to a lot of people is they
get this stuck
flow in the liver and the bile is not
going to drain properly
and so one of the things that i always
recommend when you do a detox especially
a liver detox is to first take purified
bile salts
get the drainage occurring first so you
don't get this
backup of toxins in the liver which is
very very
uncomfortable another cause is
malabsorption if you have gut damage
you're not going to be able to recycle
bile since 95
97 of all the bile in your body is
recycled
if the end part of your small intestine
is damaged or you have inflammation and
you can't recycle that
you're going to be deficient in bile and
the last reason why you might be
deficient in bile is you don't have
enough good bacteria
all right let's get back to the benefits
number seven
purify bio salts help reduce the risk of
small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth sibo why
because bile is
toxic to bacteria and one of the things
that bile does
as it's released into the small
intestine is it
kills off all the bacteria in your small
intestine
and that way you prevent bacteria from
growing in the wrong
place and so bile travels all the way
down through the small intestine kills
off the bacteria make sure it doesn't
grow
and then right at the last part it gets
reabsorbed so most of the bile is
reabsorbed into the liver
and so very little bile enters the small
intestine
and this way we keep the bacteria in the
right place the large intestine
and if there's a problem with this and
some of that bile
gets into the large intestine that's
when you have diarrhea
all right number eight and i already
mentioned this but bile greatly helps
reduce
inflammation in your liver it's a paddle
protective
it protects the liver all right last one
is this
purified bile salts reduce the toxic
load
so the toxins that are filtered out to
the liver
need bile salts to help push them out
through the small intestine
and out through the large intestine and
they also help regulate
excessive amounts of cholesterol all
right there you have it the nine
benefits of taking
purified bowel salts before you go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call and get some help